in our morning rounds how artificial
intelligence could help some patients
avoid a breast cancer misdiagnosis while
mammography is currently the most
effective and recommended breast cancer
screening tool the National Cancer
Institute says mammograms still miss
about 20% of breast cancers and one in
10 women receive a false positive result
a recent study also found false positive
breast biopsies cost the healthcare
system more than 2 billion dollars a
year Jamie yuccas spoke with researchers
at Google and UCLA who have developed
artificial intelligence programs to help
better diagnose breast cancer in
mammograms and biopsies I was absolutely
floored my mouth dropped tears came to
my eyes you have breast cancer were
words Julianne major never thought she'd
hear but what was even more shocking was
that despite diligent annual mammograms
her cancer was never detected my doctor
told me my cancer was present for at
least a decade
I had many mammograms during that decade
and not a single mammogram even after we
knew that I had cancer detected the
cancer cells after discovering a lump
during a self-exam majors cancer was
confirmed by an MRI
you know without hesitation I
immediately said I'll have a double
mastectomy major is one of the thousands
of women who every year receive a false
negative mammogram they tell me that
there's a chance that they needed to do
a biopsy normal a Carano received a
different kind of shock after a routine
mammogram she was told she needed more
testing and could possibly have breast
cancer I'm hyperventilating at that
point I was completely devastated I
couldn't hear what the doctors were
telling me you might have breast cancer
and everything else went out went out
the door vaquerano had to wait two weeks
for her biopsy results thank you that it
came false it turns out like one in ten
women in the u.s. she had originally
gotten a false positive result and in
fact did not have cancer when training
the AI system we fed at tens of
thousands of
blugh mammograms just like this one to
combat misdiagnosis
Shravya Shetty and her team at Google
developed an artificial intelligence
system to assist doctors and
pathologists to accurately detect cancer
in mammograms this is not something that
we train the system on but when we
showed at this example it identified
that here is a potential suspicious
region here is one and it turns out that
in this case this was cancerous Shetty
says their AI model reduced false
positives by almost six percent and
false negatives by about nine percent
and caught suspicious tissues on
mammograms missed by the human eye
mammograms are the best studied dr.
joanne Elmore a professor of medicine at
UCLA is the brain behind an artificial
intelligence program that helps
correctly diagnose breast biopsies would
it be a faster diagnosis or worse yeah
it would be much faster yes
the computer was trained to recognize
patterns of 240 breast biopsy images and
while still in the testing phase the
system is yielding promising results in
one test the AI program outperformed
doctors by close to 20% better accuracy
once a woman has a biopsy the tissue is
obtained and this is an example of what
the tissue can look like I took the same
exact glass slide of this and sent it to
27 different pathologists in the u.s.
they independently interpreted it and of
the 27 only 13 only 13 came back with
the right diagnosis West that's a
problem it is a problem because we have
such different recommendations for
surveillance and treatment based upon
that diagnosis in the u.s. more than
42,000 people will die from breast
cancer each year it's a statistic that
makes the promise of AI detection
critical for patients like major I was
told and I believed and I believe most
women are told the first line of defense
is having a yearly mammogram but the
mammogram failed me it failed me for a
decade for CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles dr. Susan
draftsmen is an interventional
radiologist in New York who is using
similar type of intelligence to help
screen patients for breast cancer first
and foremost dr. mammograms are still
the most effective way to detect breast
cancer mammograms are still our gold
standard they decrease mortality by
about forty percent but they have
limitations and those of us who are
expert imagers know that in dense
breasts mammography does not do the
whole job we need additional help
so ultrasound or MRI is often used but
the promise of AI for the future or a
computer assisted detection system will
definitely help us boost accuracy you're
using a computer using a computer
assisted how is it helping it helps to
draw the eye to particular regions
mammography is very much pattern based
there are certain patterns that we look
at either an area of speculation or
calcifications and those we know need to
be biopsied so with an AI system it is
trained to look at patterns and the more
it's used the better it learns so it
draws your eye to that particular area
why is there not a single set of
guidelines for women getting mammograms
I mean it rage recommendations are 40 to
55 why that variation so there is a lot
of variability between different
societies and institutions everyone
agrees mammography saves lives but there
is variability as to when to start or
how often to screen and the problem is
is that in the younger group the
discussion really centers around the
group in their 40s because that's the
group with dense breasts like this
patient who had annual mammography but
her breast cancer did not show up that's
a false negative that's where we're
doing our best work to use AI or
supplemental tests like ultrasound to
help us how important our self breast
exams when trying to find out if you
might have breast cancer early on so I
prefer not to call it self breast exams
I like to say breast self awareness
because knowing the texture the density
the contour of the breast your own
personal breast is really helpful in
being able to be your own advocates
because between mammographies or when
there is a dense breast with a false
negative if you could say hey I feel
something it is very important to do the
AI technology we saw in
in Jamie's piece you said is still
experimental that particular type of
still is not so how soon light might it
become more widely used well they need
to use it on patients not just in you
know in a setting where they're doing it
to where they know that there is a
breast cancer already diagnosed then we
need to now do testing going forward so
I would say probably within the next
year this will interface into our work
station do these same recommendations
and and procedures would they apply to
men who are also at lower risk but do
have a risk of breast cancer would it
apply to them as well male breast cancer
is very unusual accounting for less than
1% of all breast cancer so men are not
in a regular screening protocol and when
male breast cancers present they present
as a firm non tender lump behind the
nipple and usually those are much more
advanced dr. Susan Dressman thank you so
much for being with us